peu
[Musique]
eh bien nous allons vous transporter ce
soir un soir du mois de juin 1791
rasseoir vous ne vous êtes aussi chaud
aussi étouffant aussi orageux que ce
soir du moins à paris d'abord si vous le
permettez je peux vous rafraîchir
souvenirs scolaires joint 91 et bien
c'est exactement à mi-chemin entre le
début de la révolution et la chute de la
monarchie exactement vingt mois
auparavant
vingt mois auparavant le roi a été pris
à versailles a été conduit à paris par
les parricides depuis il est le
prisonnier de la révolution
cette révolution dont il entend monter
chaque soir et chaque matin et son
grondement vers lui et c'est pourquoi il
a décidé un jour de quitter paris de
s'enfuir mais n'allons pas ce soir vous
raconter la fuite des louis saez vers
varennes n'allons pas vous raconter son
départ de paris en pleine nuit
ce voyage à travers la france qui prend
quelquefois d'ailleurs des allures de
western et que vous avez d'ailleurs
raconté cible andré castelot dans vos
livres
non nous avons voulu limiter notre récit
à varennes à varennes et à une seule
nuit la nuit de varennes
nous avons trouvé en effet qu'on avait
trop tendance à raconter l'histoire de
varennes toujours à travers la famille
royale est ce qui nous a intéressés ce
sont les habitants de ce gros village de
varennes réfléchissez bien la province
en 1791 une province un peu repliée sur
elle-même une province qui est loin de
tout loin surtout de tout bruit et dans
ce gros village arrive en un seul moment
en une seule heure cet événement
prodigieux fantastique pour les vars et
n'est l'arrivée du roi de france louis
saez bien ce que nous avons cherché à
vous montrer ce soir ce sont les
réactions de ces gens simples de ces
braves gens bien ont voulu donc faire
revivre ce drame ce drame qui prend
parfois d'ailleurs des allures de
tragi-comédie dans voulu le faire
revivre sans penser continuellement à ce
calvaire que le roi et la reine vont
franchir
après cette nuit de varennes ce calvaire
ce chemin de croix qui va les conduire
un matin
janvier puis un matin d'octobre sur la
place de la révolution à paris devant la
grille la guillotine
mais ce que nous avons voulu avec ce
caillou lorenzi faire avant tout n'est
ce pas mon cher alain decaux sait faire
vrai nous sommes très riche heureusement
en documents nous possédons une masse de
dépositions de déclarations
d'interrogatoires de procès verbaux de
mémoire de souvenirs de rapports qui
nous ont permis de serrer de très près
la vérité et même nous avons essayé de
montrer les deux le décor de montrer la
configuration du terrain des lieux
exactement comme ceux trouvés varennes
autrefois et bien les habitants de
varennes aujourd'hui qu'ils ont la
télévision pourront revoir sur leur
écran
lerebours comme il l'était il ya cent
soixante neuf années ce bourg où est
mort la vieille monarchie cette nuit de
varennes ce bourg où est né en quelque
sorte l'idée du parti républicain
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le blanc et le blanc non j'y touche
j'ai tout fait à part dans la sphère
sociale et on va commencer leurs vergers
à 8 heures je sais que j'ai à me
rattraper un soir le musée toujours jose
qui gagne
hier il a fait 3 remercie et de tino la
mg m3 aurait avalé la famille attendait
tu comptes et chants du méchant des
j'étais encore à la mairie avec ce père
absent et le blanc qu'importe les
paniers la corée
[Musique]
mais plus les piémonts l'épicerie mais
quatre femmes cher via l'iran à faire
elle a la main plus lourde que toi
l'avenant merci vraiment bien peu de
poids sont ici mais j'ai bon doivent ça
prouve qu'on en vend pour les russes la
femme à son aile s'en vient le cuir
il ya des dames à force de thann et
toute la journée ben moi chez point que
chambre et je me régale au bout de sa
fourche
elle est votée mais comme ça en rangeant
si tu donnes l'écart à la gare aux
chaleurs est le blanc apporte moins vert
il est huit heures du soir il sait aussi
chanter mise y avait rejoint cette
saison avec mon blé déjà entrés one
s'est dit c'est la plus courte de
l'année et il est meilleur que celui qui
vend dans son épicerie l'arrivée prester
morue a annoncé mon salut donald seward
sauce même des chandelles sont laborieux
alors qu'ils jouent là-bas donc pas de
calais ça qu'on mange ni à gauche seul
autre gage cokerie à laruns dit moi je
vois plus mes cartes lors de compulser
de la paperasse toute la journée
vata moliets procureur janyk de la
commune angers vous allez rester dans
son épicerie allemagne va je te
conseille de parler et adjoints annoncée
pourrait venir m'aider j'ai pas trois
votes etc rien de ses traits à rennes
c'est détachement cavalerie qui
circulent dans le pays
et puis on a beaucoup qui boivent trop
qui se conduisent mal
cela dit je conduis je prends mal mais
bon là contre acquis c'est de jouer est
à toi oh pardon qui c'est celui-là
finalement comment de le détachement des
desserts qui compte encore de dire oui
l'autre qui est là bas instincts
capitaine il est français alors bonjour
bonjour aux encore fait val d'or
bon allez pas son vrai nom car c'est
faux lui qui sont des radios les voir je
vais encore perdre je vais tranquille
point de détrousseurs de tennis ans par
ici il me semble qu'ils aient 30 homsy
tirons nos roehrig tenu des signes de
meilleure tout va trés détachement après
un mondial
j'irai moi-même vous donner le signal
pour rendre à l'entrée de la règle
habituellement pour escorter le solde
des troupes
tom suffisent on notera tout même pas
m'attaquer de file à tort il n'ya même
pas au milieu vous souhaite un convoi
d'argent quelque peu particulier et
celui que vous aurez escorté cette nuit
oui je sais mais autre porte une trésor
que j'ai trois suivre à distance
respectueuse mais cheyrou sur le
capitaine qu'avec 30 ans d'ailleurs je
ne saurais même pas comment cela s'est
si chaud toute la journée alors n'est ce
pas ils se sont mis je ne fais pas
partie de votre régiment mais de dégâts
majeurs mais c'est good est cependant
votre colonne elle connaîtra votre
conduite mais mon capitaine rouissat
sont totalement et vous êtes vous même
d'origine allemand évêché de vente s'il
vous est plus facile qu'un autre
officier de tenir aux amendements n'est
pas obligé pas c'est un navire médias
les sous-officiers commune où les
tendances - quitte à prendre sa nouvelle
au lieutenant de bouder tu répondes
s'appelle résulte de choisel monsieur le
duc de choiseul couronnel du royal
dragoon rick messieurs le type de choix
seul son cul en personne de cette
mission oui c'est vous dire l'importance
exceptionnelle de ce convoi ce trésor
vous a l'exhorté ce soir et allez il est
temps de vous rendre au couvent des
cordeliers pour personnel goodsell
j'irai moi-même vous donner un signal
aux grands dans l'autre est paraît il
devra souvent émissaire et
ribes et les mêmes du belize bran 112
enfin default un lifting tavillons berne
l 611 telle procédure
on s'entend plus jouer ici que j'ai fait
a reçu au quai ce que les jeunes est en
train de devenir une grande ville
presque une vraie capitale louvain avec
une garnison 60 hommes aux cordeliers
je viens moi perso sûr que c'est
beaucoup d'honneur à lomé apprentis
c'est bien ça pour un capitaine des
canonniers de varennes cette fois que le
capitaine d'infanterie était d'humeur si
belliqueux que l'afrique est ce qui vous
tous ces gars là mais tu sais pas ils
attendent à l'hôtel du grand ménage avec
d'une cavalerie ou moins douzaine de
chevaux
oui jean président hôtels de l'île très
vaste à relais pour un présent destinée
la somme des trous ajoie est lourd tous
chevaux à madame r il en pro de l'or
pour payer l'armée de bouyer louer
presque tous des mercenaires ces gens là
et c'est curieux ben ouais ça vous
dirait pas l'idée d'aller comme sage
servir le roi de bruges où je me
souviens ça ne viendrait pas non plus à
l'été au roi d'aller engagé monsieur
coquillât à ses amours il aime se battre
ouais et si nous avons manqué avec
l'histoire il se battre entre allemands
et puis tout compte en ce mois ci à la
guerre passant je suis aux côtés mais
mais comme on cherche bien celles ci
n'ont pas fait la guerre veut c'est pour
venir au secours de la reine puisque
c'est sa soeur mais tous ces gars tarn
et de l'ess lassé des aristocrates un
horizon pour la reine par conséquent
font enfin tu as compris
bah oui enfin c'est pas très vieux ap
rabat el hadjar a dit d'ailleurs n'y a
pas de risque de guerre en ce moment un
jour j'ai parlé avec ce matin oui enfin
ça ne me déplairait pas de me dire
mettre son nez dans nos eaux
oui pas chez le frère de marie justement
à hawaï et savez bien les radars jour du
jour et puis jouer c'est l'auberge isola
vous avez des chevaux des shows bord
d'un cabriolet ou un petit cabriolet à
la wii je voyage en cabriolet par cette
chaleur vous pensez évidemment il ya la
poule 6 nominations pour l'enfant je
suis moins noir de fou d'ailleurs y
après une pause de marines aux mondiaux
comme c'est fâcheux c'est très fâché
donnez moi un verre d'orcia a de
l'argent ou un soupir de ratafia des
bonnes soeurs dans de l'hôtesse je vais
lui d'aller travailler debout y est je
suis bien à l'aise de retrouver j'ai
pour monsieur vous vous méprenez je ne
suis pas le chevalier bouyer je suis le
capitaine nous risquerons pardon mille
fois pardon mais vous avez voit les
grades des militaires
c'est pourtant charmant tous et hors du
terrain dit égalant si vous avez à faire
avec monsieur le lieutenant bouyer vous
y trouverez au grand monarque et c'est
tout près d'ici après le bond à droite
sur la base de l'église mais si vous
l'accompagnez vous devez être au courant
voilà un monsieur merci l'aubergiste je
le suis aussi
alors vous allez me donner des faux car
vous avez des chevaux des cavaliers
mais non monsieur je n'ai point de
chevaux pour vous monsieur je sais vous
avez du shbo mais qui êtes vous monsieur
léonard nous on veut le grand leona
envoyons l'inventeur du toc et en libye
léonard le coiffeur de la reine
séparation
je ne comprends pas je sais tout où j'ai
avec moi elle habite cherbourg l'habit
du roi rouge avec les broderies comme ça
il me faut des chevaux pour gagner mon
mitre vous allez montmédy et bien sûr
vous voulez vous que j'aille et vous
feriez bien d'en faire autant il y a eu
du bruit cet après midi à
sainte-menehould sainte-menehould pardon
oui on écrit stop me now would mais on
dit ça tu me new roots vous de
l'agitation
oui on rôde et des criailleries or vous
savez les populaires or mai
quelle était la cause de cette
incitation la présence à
sainte-menehould de dragon du régiment
royal
vous avez les militaires ne sont pas
toujours très comment dire je viens ne
le dit pas monsieur bah vous allez me
donner des choix que vous avez ici je
vous répète que ce n'est pas de chevaux
pour vous et ben si c'est pour leurs
droits vous les gardez vous commettez
une erreur une lourde erreur dont le
goût du jeu puisque je vous dis que je
sais tout où le roi et sa famille ont
quitté paris la nuit dernière et qui va
mal physiquement tendres ils sont partis
mais il ya toutes les chances pour que
leur voyage a été contrarié mais sur
quoi vous basez vous j'étais à tant de
somme vesle avec monsieur le duc de
choiseul où il j'ai quitté paris avec
lui dans son cabriolet
tu m'as relever comme ça on a proposé
comme je suis à courir les routes
nous avons attendu attendu
et puis comme sa majesté n'arrivait pas
monsieur le duc m'a fait la grâce de me
demander d'aller avertir les
détachements de clermont et de sable mou
mou que le trésor ne passe maintenant et
vous avez un message pour moi non
monsieur duc de choiseul a pris des
raccourcis
il devait arriver ici avant moi pour
vous voir vous ne l'avez presse mais non
or il avait pourtant avec les quarante
cavaliers de beaux hommes des hommes
superbe ça se remarque ça non oui enfin
lui aussi aura été arrêté et pas partout
vite parce que vous allez partir avec
moi certainement pas et je dois aller
passer le relais pour le wallon que la
ville d'el arrivée l'émissaire
mais l'émissaire c'est moi qui m'aurait
dit mon dieu que je deviendrais un jour
la même serre ça parte vite oui
descendant jusqu'aux grands manas o
voilà monsieur joe calzaghe me mouiller
le voilà vos sols aubergiste aof comme
ça dans les armoires
voilà
[Rires]
et où tu cours comme ça on pas vous
parfait wisselmann de postes voilà
sainte-menehould date mais nous oui si
vous voulez je viens céder les chevaux
du capitaine et du vietnam
pourquoi vous partez comme ça tout d'un
coup vous partez à la nuit enfin il va
perdre nuit dans une petite heure moi
vous savez ma mission est terminée qu'on
ma vie elle est drôle et ça lui
guillaume de la monnaie oui tu vois et
donc les suites ont fusé comme pièce oui
sans les deux voitures et les courriers
qui viennent de relayer à hesmond règle
en petites pièces
c'est au fond 1 j'aime mieux ça que les
assignats en chevaux qui m'ont pris non
il reste plus que la roussette non
j'espère qu'il viendra pas de voiture
avant un bout de temps les hommes de
clermont vont pas être venu avant 10
heures et encore sa garde si ça donc ça
va non c'est embêtant pour toi que le
détachement [ __ ] le camp
ça a marché est en auberge mais ce qui
est ennuyeux c'est à cause d'eux et à
cause du détachement qui est passé hier
pour prendre ce mail que jenny deux
barriques en perse il ya eu des
pressions rigoureux qu'en prépa maths a
fait du bénéfice
les détachements d'aristocrates ça
regarde pas à la dépense
je me plains pas surtout grâce à elle on
a touché des fusils qu'elle physique
ah oui ce que le département avait
envoyé la municipalité s'était pas là
cet après midi ah non moi je vais pas
quitter mon champ de la malassise bah
oui sont les gens en voyant passer des
dragons sans parler des hussards d'hier
qui ont cru qu'on allait avoir la guerre
et qu'on allait devoir se défendre
il va y avoir la guerre la guerre moi
m'a rien dit non ya pas de guerre froide
ont escorté la paye des troupes un
trésor
c'est vrai ça vous attendez le passage
d'un trésor et vous partez sans croire
qu'il n'est pas seul il est passé 10
points
ces trésors que vous lui escorté suivre
a dit specta distance respectable ce
sont les ordres c'est pas la berline
verte et jaune la berline et cabriolet
en moi je supporte on a dit c'est les
choix du capitaine et du lieu
dis donc qu'est ce que tu as regardé
cette pièce là tu as vu qu'il était dans
la berline
ah oui des femmes un gros bonhomme haut
avec un grand nez ça j'ai pas très bien
vu et assembler ce profil au roi oui
guillaume c'est peut-être le roi qui
vient de passer
c'était fou bah tu vas voir
non pourquoi tes camarades ont salué la
berline quand elle a traversé la place
devant l'hôtel de ville
j'ai vu une dame dans la voiture qui
nous saluer comme ça alors pourquoi de
reste on a salué est en capitaine ton
capitaine qui pendant qu'on change et
les chevaux leur a parlé la main au
casque pourquoi c'est bien qu'ils les
connaissent
ce sont des aristocrates qu'il faut deux
clans rivaux étrangers la france de
condé les courriers de la berline avec
la livrée jaune des domestiques du
prince de condé ya longtemps qu'il est
parti lui je te dis que c'est peut-être
le roi qui est passé le roi qui fout le
camp à l'étranger le roi et toute sa
famille alors voir se lever d'un bref
ces gauches pas l bout de celle
questionner - puis cinq minutes
justement donc je pars je dis pas bougé
et que tu vas aller à l'hôtel de ville
tu vas leur dire que que je crois bien
voir reconnues le roi alors oui le roi
qui s'enfuyaient dit alors qu'il faut
pas laisser les dragons passé qu'un
troll cheval du capitaine payera plus
vite
vous êtes fous non je suis pas fou il
faut pas perdre de temps c'est le roi
qui vient de passer tout comprendre non
je comprends pas j'ai pas d'ordre à
recevoir de vous c'est ce qu'on va voir
est légal est de le mettre à les
rejoindre leurs aînés ils pour attraper
la berline
dépêchons-nous il au madrigal en avant
qu'est ce que vous faites là bas on
faisait la cause notre lettre et la
berline et le cabriolet
vous avez aller ya clairement il ya une
demi-heure le meilleur et ils ont
continué vers verdun
non notre m j'ai entendu une veste jaune
vidéo camarades de clermont route de
varennes août devant n ya pas de maison
de postes là bas et je vous jure même
qu'on les a vus prendre la route à
gauche et mathieu grand merci
on va prendre le raccourci à gauche vous
tourneront pas de pêche oui par le faire
ça va nous mener directement sur la
route de varennes
ouais c'est parce qu'ils soient du
dorset sur pied ce pays
voilà on va passer devant les opa celle
qui nous reconnaîtrons pas
[Musique]
le cas
oui
échec et mat
et voilà mon cher capitaine quand vous
voudrez une entre le sent bon capitaine
alors vous êtes à m
[Musique]
il va falloir les kouchis la 2010 air
vient de sonner
demain matin de 7 à 9 avant la
procession de la fête-dieu exercice de
la garde nationale et entend conserver
et voulait faire le blanc owen sera
comme tous les dimanches et jours fériés
soyez porte un monde
mon cher capitaine nous ferez vous
l'honneur de votre présence et celle de
vos deux couleuvrine de couleuvre ils se
sont tus depuis la bataille de marignan
un peuple
ça ne fait rien mais avec elle je vous
assure que vous et vos hommes entrant
vous prive rinne vous avez perdu
couleuvrine son sang a pu par conséquent
d'un transport comme en double et
l'effet sur la place de la mairie où tu
aurais ça suffira tirait me suis lancé
avec quelques personnes nous ont jamais
dit vrai mais si vous le voulez vous
accompagnerez en voyant tous ces
militaires qui circulent dans la région
suis comme vous sent d'humeur guerriero
et bien rejoindre
es-tu patriotes camarades qu'y at il
pour votre service monsieur le patriote
je suis drogué jean baptiste drouet
maître de poste de sainte menou
bon et alors le roi va passer le roi
veut pas chez vous ici par dj à varennes
et qu'en cinq ans mais tout de suite on
les produits noël la municipalité en
saurait il s'annonce droit partie voyage
sur la robe de l'autre il a dû s'enfuir
de paris avec la famille ils sont passés
chez moi bien huit heures je crois d
avoir reconnu le croyait c'est parce que
vous croyez que vous avez ici et vous
lui avez parlé vous rois mages l'a
entendu parlé tout à l'heure à l'entrée
du bourg
mais quels mots hell bourg de bahreïn le
roi est à l'entrée du bourg rural et si
c'était vrai ça sort mais c'est vrai
mais il cherchait le relais de poste
comprend des passes et des guillemins
bien sûr il n'a pas de maison de postes
si c'est le roi il faut l'arrêter ou
arrêter l'empêcher de [ __ ] le camp
l'étranger et vous comprenez pas que
s'il passe il va nous amener la guerre
en affranchir et près d'ici et aller
chercher du secours
ses frères et tous les artistes pâtit
depuis deux ans passent devant la maison
de postes ils sont nombreux maintenant
empereur d'autriche pas qu'il va venir
donner un coup de main son beau-frère
pour que tout redevienne comme avant la
prise de la bastille leur voiture va
passer dans cinq minutes devant
l'auberge ou alors il faut l'arrêter
alors demandé leur passeport
franck la syndic de la commune c'est la
plus haute autorité du pays et où est il
il doit enfin moi je vais aller le
réveiller votre chauffe et ou de martil
au niveau guillaume pendant ce temps là
on rigole pas réformes attendues alors à
l'épicerie qu'il a un peu plus beau et
on pourrait arrêter la voiture quand
elle passera la main sous la voûte
alors voila quoi tes péchés vous vous
êtes pas dégourdi et godewaersvelde et
loudéac apprend la charrette bas quand
les cercles ben oui j'allais à l'hôpital
où il est je vais réussir ma part y
aller chercher vos fusils et prévenez
les arguments un bon capitaine vous
pourriez peut-être amener vos cadeaux
non ils ne feront jamais venir jusqu'ici
bon je vais prévenir le major roland tis
et le roy on sera pas de trop au goût
c'est parce qu'il a mis ont tapé au
avant j'y vais et aux abeilles habitants
a maintes fois mais il faut le temps
qu'ils sa main vous n'êtes pas égaux ni
vraiment à part et non aux passageois
oui ça doit sauter dépêche toi au port
j'ai sûrement des militaires qui vont
faire et comment décor de leur nez plein
quelque chose d'aussi on attrape au
point que mes tempes lors du la caution
pas prenez vos rues mais n'a pas froid
surtout
comme ça qu'est ce qui allait vite le
roi et la reine sont dans le pays
1 on renonce le prendre aux mots jetés
en train de dormir mais pas l'air de
vouloir présenter non je suis pas
certain que ce soit le roi mais si c'est
lui c'est qu'il essaie de s'enfuir or si
vous n'êtes pas certain mais ça va pas
recommencer non mais oui perso ce poids
il paraît que c'est le roi ne l'a bien
expliqué tout à l'heure aux intéressés
le roi il faut l'arrêter arrêter l'ordre
avaient bien sûr il forme à l'étranger
alors arrêtez le roi même mais c'est
impossible
ouais on ne peut pas arrêter le roi et
s'il a semblé leur donner à l'assemblée
l'assemblée oui elle appartenait d'or de
l'assemblée un l épaule à l'assemblée
tandis que les soirs ils sont un peu là
vous en avez beaucoup madame 60 sans
compter les officiers qui sont au grand
monarque
ça prouve qu'ils attendent quelque chose
me with attendent quelque chose qu'on
voit d'argent un trésor mais ce serait
forcée nauroy pardi mais ensuite ça nous
allait il faut se dépêcher
et voilà et auraient ils sont 60 et joue
on est 3e au bras d'or il ya person
coquillard duch alors les deux frères
leblanc et justin georges haoui le
capitaine ou et puis on est allé
chercher la garde nationale enfin je
retrouve à quoi ils ont des fusils
maintenant de fusion de pétoires qui
partent pas ou qui partent tout seul
alors on en avait demandé au département
des 9 février j'ai écrit l'autre semaine
mais ils ont bien dans le référé un
aller bâle est faux car maintenant il
faut leur demander leurs passeports aux
sports on voyage pas sans passeport
ah ouais c'est pas drôle ça et puis ça
vous engage à rien les passeports sont
peu oui à l'image on y allait aller peut
pas y aller comme ça
mais non marisa
et on dit ça parce que s'il avait oui
allez viens viens taper choisi attendait
marrison réveille les enfants et 10 lors
de courir à travers le bourg en criant
au feu
ah bon c'est fait oui il ya le feu chez
qui j'ai envie de crier au feu allez
[Musique]
tiens moi ça tu veux bhopal mon chapeau
vais laisser passez à l'ordre le pont
une barre et oui avec jared de vacances
il déménagera d'autres passionnés le
coût de celle aux cordeliers avait déjà
prouvé sur les wii 60 gaillard il
sauvera la main oui plus jeune artiste à
l'éclosion du chant dès le round 5
oui mais les haïtiens sont aussi il y en
aura pas d'issue rejoindre les parisiens
comme pioneer on peut toujours celui de
taratata qui dorment depuis 4 heures
c'est à dire que mon vin il va droit au
but voilà où est rangé un détour par le
président quand on n'est pas content tu
avec lé bois rhône a annoncé par des
morts sont anwar est pas sûr que ce soit
lui
hélas cette berline bahia trois minutes
ils étaient en route du bourg mais les
postillons monter en selle je les ai vus
de loin et ils ont bien accepté de
doubler la poste moi on a dû les payer
ils sont tous en renard peut-être c'est
là que renée desbiens laissez-vous et
chantant les voitures quoi
mais nous sommes de la poste clairement
le jour grâce du kck fort s'il vous
plaît aux passeports s'il vous plaît que
se passe-t-il
bompas cordes aubry
veuillez fournir la femme de chambre et
les dents cabriolet qui nous y aller la
chercher
la voici madame voulais vous présenter
le passeport à ces messieurs
chez vous nous avons à tergnier oui mon
entrée en jeu
je suis le procureur indique de
varaignes voulais vous montrer ce
passeport à tous officiers civils et
militaires chargés de surveiller de
maintenir l'ordre public dans les
différents départements du royaume et à
tous autres qu'il appartiendra cellule
passé la formule à passer tout ça on va
je vous prie de me laisser lire à ma
convenance
on avait je sais bien que les maîtres de
poste ont l'habitude de galoper et moi
je suis épicier nous mentons et or de
nom vous ayez un laissez passer
librement librement oui je vois la
baronne de corse à lanta francfort mais
francfort c'est par la route fallait
aller clairement ce n'est pas nous qui
avons fait l'itinéraire monsieur sans
doute que madame la baronne de cordes
désiré passaient par le luxembourg
oui à francfort avec deux enfants une
femme et un valet de chambre et trois
domestiques sans lui donner ni souffrir
qu'il lui soit donné aucun empêchement
ne présent passeport valable pour un
mois seulement donné à paris le 5 juin
1791 signé louis pour le roi mme
montmarin oui c'est le ministre ouais
mais à vous qui êtes vous madame je suis
madame bruni la femme de chambre de
madame la baronne de corps à la baronne
d'accord c'est la dame qui vous a donné
le passeport non monsieur c'est celle
qui était à ses côtés
eh ben
vous paraît tout à fait en règle se
passe comme un peu plus régulier il est
même signé louis c'est même ce qui a dû
être le plus facile à faire comme mon
cher puisque le voyageur qui es dans la
voiture c'est le roi louis leroy
là il a eu qu'à signer son passeport lui
même puisque c'est leur droit et non
marin il est dans la voiture
non non et moi dans tout seul je vois
aucun motif pour arrêter des voyageurs
et les empêcher de continuer leur route
une route qui va les conduire au
territoire étranger et à la parce que
vous croyez toujours c'est la famille
royale et bien sûr mais non messieurs
c'est madame la baronne de corse qui est
dans la voiture et le gros monsieur qui
est en face d'elle elle et deux enfants
ce sont les enfants de madame la baronne
de corse
deux petites filles de petite fille deux
enfants le dauphin et madame royal une
femme c'est la reine la baronne de corps
doit être madame elisabeth avaler
chambre c'est le roi avec son chapeau
galonnés et trois domestiques trois
femmes madame et les deux autres qui
sont dans la voiture et la berline à la
famille royale moi je la voyais pas
comme ça mais puisqu'on vous dit que
c'est le roi ses trois arrêts ne s'est
jamais vu enfin tout ça ce ne sont que
des indices pas de certitudes avant je
suis certain que ces droits
oui je pense comme toi drouet c'est la
famille royale à madame si vous laissez
passer leur voix vous vous rendez
coupable d'un crime à redon monsieur la
crème misa ville qui vis-à-vis de
l'assemblée mais le ministre responsable
devant l'assemblée comme il l'est devant
le roi signé le passeport que milan
signe sans tous les matins là il a dû
signer celui là même si les pas du
complot un complot mais bien sûr c'est
en cachette que le roi a quitté paris en
cachette de l'assemblée vous l'aurez
peut être monsieur sauce laisser fuir le
roi c'est un crime crème voilà un bien
grand mot et surtout difficilement
applicable en droit
quand vous allez me dire qu'un voix ne
fuit pas et il prend congé mais ici ils
fuient le laissez passer sera une
trahison parce que laisser le roi en
admettant que ce folique n'ayez pas eu
des visions laisser le roi perse qui lui
plaît comme ses prédécesseurs depuis
plus d'un millier d'années serait une
trahison vis à vis de l'assemblée
briller vis-à-vis de la nation
c'est à dire de nous tous ouais
oui vous avez peut-être raison
comment peut-être mais messi droit passe
la frontière nous aurons la guerre vous
pensez que c'est le passé pour aller
chercher du secours
la guerre vous n'avez pas eu assé
autrefois narbonne ils nous abandonnent
il abandonne la nation la nation et en
tant que procureur syndic de varennes
vous êtes responsable
j'y vais
pour
descendez quoi vous méprenez monsieur
mais faut descendre de notre passeport
est en règle
oui parfaitement en règle mais il doit
être examiné demain matin par la
municipalité
mais c'est contraire aux usages
l'autorité qui arrêtent des voyageurs
paisible côte est habilité à viser un
passeport immédiatement demain matin on
verra on verra quoi
si sur la dernière un sens vous n'avez
pas le droit de retenir des voyageurs
madame la baronne de corse et étrangère
qu'elle retourne chez elle en russie
elle est une amie de la tsarine vos
chevaux ne peuvent continuer se
rafraîchir et d'ailleurs la nuit et si
noir que vous ne vous en tirerez pas
mieux vaut décembre je suis le majordome
de madame la baronne de cov c'est moi
qui organise son voyage un relais nous
attend à l'hôtel du grand monarque un
relais non il n'y en a pas il n'y a pas
de relais à varennes
mesdames veillée décembre à sion en
haute mais ils deviennent mes cheveux
monsieur et puis il faut que nous
rentrions à clermont nous je vous donne
l'ordre la partie si vous bougez veut
dire ces procédés sont elles fiables
seront supportés des menaces si vous
faites un seul pas venir
un retard dans le voyage de madame la
baronne de cov peut lui porter un
préjudice considérable dont la
municipalité de varennes sera
responsable
soit nous acceptons cette responsabilité
est bien
descendons puis nous ne quittons pas la
friture voyons monsieur
madame la baronne
je ne vois pas d'autres solutions
et maintenant monsieur ou devons-nous
rares si vous voulez bien venir jusqu'à
chez moi c'est à deux pas vous y serez
mieux qu'ici les les enfants surtout
voyous c'est là bas à gauche
l'épicerie
[Musique]
pourquoi stokes un bal doit y avoir le
feu quelque part madame monsieur
vous voulez bien d'entrée contre et
français je vous en prie rentrée si vous
voulez bien monté c'est au premier vous
verrez c'est pas très grand mais c'est
bon coeur pas la peine de nous parler
autant de la liberté pour agir ainsi
il est certain que l'on était beaucoup
plus libre de voyager autrefois
pourquoi
à
[Musique]
c'est pas possible
pourquoi pas précisément h ronald cette
perruque rousse non au nom d'allah et
c'est pas pu s'y tient mal à son
portrait
[Musique]
ouais et une sacrée différence
ramare qui se promènent rarement comme
soeur venir chose et c'est pourrions
blanche avec ge noire des ermites
il était déguisé là tu produis si le roi
voulait s'en aller sans n'irai pas avec
toute sa famille par la même route des
avec une berline qui a l'air d'un
monument c'est un corniaud leroy cette
rue la municipalité à 8 heures d'écouté
le kart de sainte-menehould bat qu'on
est en train de faire une bêtise du
pause popul tier iii en crèches du monde
toujours là où est ce que les gens qui
le maire fait toujours absente tant
entendu et jamy de l'aide varie mais il
faut aller à l'hôtel de ville
délibéré voilà on va venir concernant la
cl et en montrant pelé les autres rôles
on pense à rester avec moi et bout du 4e
n'est ce pas madame bien sûr madame
[Musique]
j'allais voir il a du coup
l'épais il a du corps d'une manière est
inconcevable de recevoir de paisibles
voyageurs
je fais ce que je peux madame ce n'est
pas pour vous que je dise la madame
c'est pour votre mari pour mon mari mais
il n'est pas aussi pour marie claude
gilli notre façon de recevoir les
voyageurs est étrange
nous vous aimons madame non
on est venu nous dire que votre
domestique là c'était le roi le
majordome de la baronne devra évidemment
je suis le majordome de madame la
baronne de kort
oui donc c'est pas moi madame on nous
l'a dit alors on l'a cru
eh bien monsieur si vous le croyez vous
devriez déjà être à ses pieds et si
c'est un étranger de quel droit l'arrêté
vous alors vous trouvez que je ressemble
le roi ben oui 20 non aux pommes jamais
vu droit
tamboura présent après le tox ah ah oui
il ya un peu pareil je voulais dit alors
on est allé chercher la garde nationale
pour donner un coup de main il faut que
j'aille voir le feu ben oui le feu j'ai
une idée
enfin je peux dire excusez moi
marie-jeanne tu t'occupes de ces
messieurs-dames tu leur donnes du vin à
boire du tu pourrais peut-être ont donné
un petit peu aux enfants sains les frais
dormir excusez moi
[Musique]
d'après les deux banques financent nos
capitaines catane et leurs 2 bat de
temps là bien sûr loto que ça ne suffit
pas pour les re telle alliance nationale
pour le feu il répond bien aiguisé
manche mais cette phase mais pourquoi ça
va j'y perde en avant d'acheter oublie
son passé nerveux comme ça bah oui c'est
vrai c'est comme l'an dernier 14 juillet
pour la fête de la fédération tout le
monde est dans la rue ils viennent tous
vous voir le roi pour le protéger ou
pour l'empêcher de partir ou le garder
price a elle même pas pourquoi moi donc
nous avons un gros bonhomme qui n'était
que le domestique d'une tannerie ont
longtemps mais c'est le roi mais oui
mais oui j'en suis certain mon coeur il
croise à toi quand il ya ba il n'est pas
bien ou alors moi je suis prononcé un
bon dieu je vois pas comment on peut
citer oui on vous qui voulez vous que
toutes ses troupes a été placé il ya des
dragons et des housses avant tout les
boules entre chalon et montmédy demain
c'est mort à 13h protégé est bas mais ce
trésor c'est le roi c'est possible non
mais vous vous rendez compte 60 us arize
150 dragon à clermont show cavaliers à
tort dans les dix et je sais pas combien
sommes-nous et apple sont belles mais
tout ça pour la somme de des troupes
une somme qui aurait pu être escortés
par quelques gendarmes une maintenance
et le royaume uni au 01 30 il se passer
si vous arrêtez et commence à bien le
dire juste un jeune il a beaucoup de
monde encore en sommes venus m'avait dit
mais tous ces détachements de cavalerie
vont converger sur barel et son conseil
municipal formé chez vrai bon jeu
l'histoire à kirk ont été aussi
tranquille est la moisson et et b2b
plein jour qu'à venir les dragons
responsable et recevoir audrey lamy
citoyen qu'il dans l'oubli encore un
détail mais lequel
oui un détail d'importance le général de
brouiller général de brouiller qui se
trouve à trois ou quatre heures d'ici se
tenait ou à montmédy avec un régiment
entier le royal allemand à l'allemand
oui monsieur pelletier
plus de deux mille hommes sans compter
d'autres régiments qui se trouve à
montmédy et bien et bien fait ce que
vous croyez que c'est la famille royale
vous avez arrêté que va-t-il se passer
je vous le demande eva reverdy brouillé
tous ces savants quelques heures vous
tombez sur le nom comment il me serait
mouillé qu'on a arrêté le roissy
aussitôt après l'arrestation ces
voyageurs suspecte mon avis il
officiellement commandé le détachement
s'enfuir avec les deux blancs becs qui
se trouvait trop grand monarque et
s'enfuir avec les chevaux et les chevaux
du relais wi du relais et commencent à
réclamer on a vu comment ce que parce
que faisait mine de talents et vous
n'avez pas commis après n'ont essayé de
faire glisser mes canons n'en croyez moi
quand on ne doute que ces deux officiers
ne soit allé prévenir monsieur de bouyer
il dans quelques heures ce sera ici avec
ses sabreurs et j'ai même pu tester
alors je ferai une juge pas il doit
dormir annuel cheveux il vient tuer non
mais non mais non je suis passé chez lui
j'ai pas ça pour acter waro conteneurs
qui étaient en promenade
j'y vais et qu'est ce que tu peux
attester mais il a vite et versailles
lui connaît le roi non ah bah oui mais
oui c'est pareil ça m'étonne qu'il faut
leur trouver le langage si votre fils
d'esther reconnaît le roi que se
passera-t-il 1 à bochum chez rien
n'allait l'arrêter
oui pourquoi pas une fois arrêté qu'est
ce qu'on ferait du bien vous le demande
n'en croyez moi mieux vaudrait que le
gros bonhomme galonnés soit réellement
un domestique bien sûr madame que vous
avez tort de s'inquiéter
pourquoi n'avez-vous pas ordonné aux
gardes du corps de faire usage de leurs
armes tous ces gens là pouvaient être
culbuter je n'ai jamais fait verser le
sang de mes sujets ça n'est pas
aujourd'hui que je commencerai si vous
c'est le faire c'est n'avait été avec
nous pourquoi l'avoir renvoyée à bondy
ne vous avez dit paquet quitter paris
sans incidents
je ne pouvais voyager sous la protection
de monsieur de fersen vous savez très
bien pourquoi madame mieux que personne
vous m'aviez premier monsieur de ne
point prêter l'oreille à ce que vous
savez parfaitement être des calomnies
certes madame vous connaissez ma
confiance
ma compréhension si de faire ce n est un
ami un ami sur un des rare que nous
ayons il nous est dévouée jusqu'à la
mort et je vous assure que si tout à
l'heure il avait été là il aurait tiré
sur le peuple madame monsieur fersen et
suédois suédois au service de la france
il ya des choses que peut faire un
colonel suédois au service de la france
et que ne peut point faire un roi de
france
même sans verser du sang du patient avec
lui c'est monsieur le faire 5 qui a
préparé notre départ il connaît le
relais le bahreïn il nous aurait conduit
au lieu de cela nous sommes restés dix
minutes 20 minutes au bout de ce village
20 minutes qui ont tout perdu mais non
madame rien n'est encore perdu
on n'avait rien à craindre il ya là une
cinquantaine de hussards qui ont disparu
oui leur disparition est aussi
inexplicable que celle du capitaine de
ré secours et du jeune poignée de bouyer
qui devait veiller sur les relais peut
être un apprenant notre arrestation sont
ils partis chercher du secours
soit on love madame souhaitons là
cependant
nous aurions tort de nous désespérer
continuons à nier ces gens là ne nous
ont pas reconnu
[Musique]
ça
j'ai révisé en baisse serait gentil au
roi enfin au gros quoi j'ai alors eu ce
problème ça mais il a vu le roi à
versailles lui le vrai j'ai ouï oui même
qui nous a raconté comment il se
lèverait tu vas quand tu te souviens il
nous a dit qu'il y avait une foule de
grands seigneurs qui ne contempler se
laver les mains et le visage à l'alcool
et même qu'on pouvait aller voir sur sa
chaise percée ici sera plus tranquille
[Musique]
c'est ici enfin si c'est ici monsieur
est bien sûr de les reconnaître
oui bien sûr mon beau père voilà rennes
tous les jours tu lis très votre compère
n'est pas vous mais moi je les ai vu
cent fois à versailles
bon bon et ben ventron
[Musique]
bonjour
six ans
[Musique]
eh bien oui
je suis votre roi
[Musique]
j'ai quitté paris parce que ma famille
était chaque jour destinée à périr
j'en avais assez de vivre au milieu des
baïonnettes et je suis venu me réfugier
chez mes fidèles sujets à sire vous êtes
ici en sûreté ne faut rien craint aussi
je sais
j'aime bien chez dire mon rêve c'était
d'aller boire manger à versailles as tu
m'aurais dit que ce serait une chose que
je vous retrouverai la municipalité de
varennes vous écouter vous réussir j'en
suis convaincu
messieurs
je comprends votre étonnement de me voir
vêtu ainsi mais si vous saviez mes amis
les sacrifices que j'ai consenti pour la
nation vous comprendriez mon départ tous
les pouvoirs sont méconnus la sûreté des
personnes est mise en danger mais vaud
va notre majesté n'aurait-elle pas pu
proclamer franchement qu'elle partait
pour la province 18 avril
roy a voulu comme l'an dernier passer
quelques jours à saint claude
eh bien nous avons été assiégé dans
notre voiture par des enragés les
parisiens exalté poussé par les ennemis
de la monarchie nous n'avons pas pu
partir et avons été contraints de
regagner notre prison car on ne peut
véritablement pas acté les twin rien
oublié partir pour saint cloud afin de
recevoir vos packs des mains d'un prêtre
l'ayant pas prêté serment à la
constitution
cela ne regarde que moi monsieur il
serait étonnant qu'après avoir donné la
liberté à la nation je suis pas libre
moi même
n'est-il pas naturel que j'ai cherché
recouvré la liberté à me mettre en
sûreté ainsi que ma famille auprès de
mes fidèles sujets des trois évêchés
évidemment évidemment aussi messieurs je
vous demanderai de faire un thé ma
voiture sans plus attendre davantage
afin que je poursuive marque
certainement sur certainement
votre majesté va rendre visite à ses
sujets de l'est on interroge point le
roi les sujets qui sont bien près d'une
frontière
si le frontier qu'il est facile de
franchir on attention n'est nullement de
sortir de francs nom et qui vous permet
monsieur denis malleval soir regardez le
dos de votre passeport si votre
itinéraire il est tracé sans doute de
votre main sainte-menehould clairement
varennes d'un stoney montmédy luxembourg
un pointillé juin montmédy à luxembourg
escudé discuter pointait nous disculper
auprès d'eux il est de mon devoir non
pas de me disculper
mais de relever une erreur mon intention
était et est toujours de rester à
montmédy et de passer la frontière si
vos affaires ne se rétablissent pas mais
qui êtes vous monsieur ayrault et jean
baptiste drouet maître de poste de
sainte menou c'est moi qui vous ai
reconnu lorsque vous avez relayé chez
moi enfin vous n'avez pas le droit de
prendre la parole chaque fois ce droit
[Musique]
je parle cyr au nom de la nation que
vous ou trajets en n'ayant point
confiance en elle comment faire
confiance en ceux qui nous menace nous a
juré la nation que vous ou trajets en
voulant l'abandonner et vous
il me semble que vous oubliez un peu la
nation vous aurez des comptes à rendre à
tout le pays à toute la france
si vous favorisez le départ du roi le
conseil municipal de varennes n'a pas de
leçon à recevoir de vous monsieur roux
et voyez vous retirer
[Musique]
voilà entre gens honnêtes je suppose que
vous avez entendu le mois fait tacler
monsieur oui vous majesté pourront
repartir mais au jour seulement au jour
avec une escorte de gardes nationaux de
varennes c'est ça a eu une centaine de
cars dont nous n'avons nul besoin de vos
gardes nationaux il ya ici un
détachement des usa ah oui mais ils
boivent depuis ce matin et leur chef est
parti
bon ben ali à t'apprendre une
cinquantaine de gardes et puisqu'on
pourra trouver de us à ces biens soient
j'ai confiance dans la municipalité de
ma bonne ville de varennes merci cyr
venez
on
[Musique]
comme ça longtemps sûr d'avoir la
victoire
moi je crois que c'est assez simple mais
non prévisibles
on peut très bien faire ça mais qu'est
ce qu'on vient chercher pire
oui un côté loser bouchard a expliqué
que les détachements des hussards se
trouvait technicien juillet ça y est
c'est à l'endroit où s'était pas trop
envie et appareils et puis y écouter le
camp le désir de la nation la volonté
des députés qui doit représenter c'est
parce que c'est un caddie le roi alors
il nous a toujours envoie ses cd même
que c'est pas agréable parce qu'il est
un territoire qui vos rêves et wachovia
que je m'étais embrassé par la paroisse
qui abandonne son poste c'est pas un
mois comme un autre endroit comme la
prose doit d'en avoir un à la retirant
au jour avec plus des scores de tes
gardes nationaux pour la compet effet ce
qu'a fait laurent milliard avec nous
captain mais moi aussi je vais vous
accompagner un voeu à ça voulait pas
dégourdi alors un bar hen wlad et
pourquoi mais nous à sainte-menehould ya
longtemps qu'on a compris un diplôme
bien sûr bien longtemps enfin accompagné
le roi vous rappelez pas quand les
parisiens sont allés les chercher à
versailles en octobre il n'ya pas moi
d'accompagner et où je te prie que ça
m'étonne pas que tu t'appelles cotillard
aussi tu t'appelles john njue rebelles
drouet mais je ne vais pas le roi mais
l'accompagné ou je te voyais ou à
montmédy
et là que fera t-il enfin il passera la
frontière et nous ramènera la guerre
eh bien j'y reviens graphique ou comme
un dératé je vais repartir pour paris
leur annoncer la nouvelle
et la demande est ce qu'il faut faire et
je peux y aller moi ah non c'est affaire
de varens a tenté un bon cheval
alors avant l'arrivée des sages pour
n'être long métrage la wii et sony je
plais morneau il me voir la santé de la
star
depuis quand je dors a régaté il ya ce
délire pour les commander un
maréchal-des-logis charlott' échasses de
logis charles ou charleville 15h
sous-officier calais puis à patriotes
comme new wave awards que la mer va
quand ils parlent l'allemand leur a dit
ça va dire devancé vous êtes trop
concitoyens et trop console d'abord vous
pourrez dire les boissons du roy et nous
perdu malin vers toi même pas cela par
les nôtres ceux qui sont passés hier
voilà clairement et après nous sommes
allés à chalon ils sont bien une
cinquantaine ou sa part d'accord mais là
orange est en bataille et leur chef est
un grand cap deux colonels blond un tube
parait-il
il a été voir encore de lien pour moi au
genre récupérer les trois fois tiens bon
janot cubes d'eau douce et regarde cela
ait des patriotes club de rêve de la
nation leduc alicia vécu il les a rendus
en allemand la hotoie l'hôtel de ville
reine qui leur a dit qu'ils se plient
passé mais je crois avoir compris
il leur a dit qu'ils allaient devoir
mourir ou délivrer le roi et la reine
qu'ils allaient se couvrir de noir elle
perd sourde oreille de hausse
so we will pay ressources leur a dit il
était trop bon citoyen pour faire couler
du sang mais même ici il y piquer ippon
par l'allemand de personnes aimées par
les ports en faisant des gestes rohr
[Musique]
12h15 écoutez moi
mieux vaudrait ne sais pas quel endroit
bien pas mal à vous êtes tous laissés
par ses mémoires avant l'été comme on
verrait démarré comme 6,40 à l'aller
résume en deux mais c'est le pigeon
comprendra les bains nous nous
défendrons vous défendrez avec des
fusils contre plus de 2000 ans bien
avant bien sûr qu'on défendra je radote
est très gentil qui ont léché quoi c'est
le roy on sèmera la force
après on serait tranquille on aurait
plus dans lui les ennuis mais non pas
les ennuis c'est pas pour nous la nation
n'aurait bien d'avancer h et s'il envoie
n'étaient pas arrêtés à leur retour leur
d'abord et les trois ils sont la nation
mais il dit à la nation c'est toi
laissez-moi veille celle où tout
s'enchaîne bien bochum à sannois chez
chabrol enfin moi je suis très fier je
préfère ma peau que je saigne à la
chasse à braire l'amo et le mot résume
ils n'auront pas peur
pas plus peur de votre garde nationale
que peu de mecs sains en planque nous
courons en danger c'est vrai mais nous
ne sommes pas des lâches non il faut
garder le roi il y va du sort du pays à
tout le pays
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais
15 balles hier de la porte et que
personne ne m'en aille bungie d'abord où
se trouve leur majesté
mais sa majesté la reine est monté dans
cet escalier ne pas te laisser disperser
comme une volée de moineaux
je ne voulais mettre les maîtres comment
mon cher du blues ici à part elle fait
tout expliquer votre majesté mais ces
nouveaux prix chez nous mais c'est du
passé nous devions nous rencontrer à
prendre sont belles et en est un signe
de progrès nous est prévu entre va
j'espère vite un tel retard une et trois
heures sur l'horaire prévu pour le 7
juillet monsieur versailles
nous n'avons fait que le départ était
manquée vous avez cru certes nous avions
un peu de retard nous avons perdu deux
heures à notre départ de paris et nous
avons eu un accident à champery mais de
là à croire que notre départ était
manquée la presse a pour le sommet les
paysans en voyant arriver les hussards
sont devenus menaçant si oui il n'avait
pas payé dans un bourg il pensait que
nous venions les mettre à la raison
enfin bref sommes repliés par des
raccourcis les raccourcis qui vous ont
amené ici deux heures un point d'eau
je vous en veux charles mon cher
choiseul je sais que vous avez essayé de
faire pour le mieux
que sont devenus les détachements de
sainte-menehould est de clairement
qu'ils delémont durant celle-ci tour
notre passage nous suit les jeux
l'ignorent madame hudon préféra d'éviter
ces deux sens que j'avais averti du
retard du roi par yona yona votre
coiffeur madame mais oui monsieur
léonard nous est tout dévoué n'est ce
pas mon cher des coups sûrs et madame
assure enfin monsieur de choiseul je ne
comprends pas pourquoi l avoir pris avec
vous une tête si légère
monsieur qui est demandé au duc de
choiseul de véhicules et les eaux là
jusqu'à vomir
comment on va j'étais coincé en arrivant
vous pouvez me présenter aux troupes
ainsi c'est madame les cheveux au vent
votre majesté utt la souveraine tente en
vain de sceptre de la beauté je crois
pas d'âme qu'en l'occurrence mieux valu
que vous soyez un peu des peignées leona
certains messieurs je ne pense pas que
monsieur de fersen but approuvé par et
choix si mme est il permis de poser une
question je vous en prie vous gérez où
se trouve le jeune cavalier de bouyer et
le capitaine leur âge tour mais je n'ai
pas seulement aperçu ces messieurs dames
11 ans je les croyais est tué sur la
voiture de votre majesté mais ils
devaient se trouvait à l'entrée du bourg
avec les relais je ne les ai pas vus
alors au bout d'une vingtaine de minutes
les bottes ci ont accepté de nous
conduire jusqu'au grand monarque
c'est en effet là où se trouvait le
relais mais pourquoi ces messieurs ne
l'ont ils pas conduit à l'entrée de la
reine se voit qu'une seule réponse à
donner à cette disparition
votre coiffeur qu'aviez vous monsieur
vous acharnez pareillement contre mon
coin saint léonard d'inversion aucun
ordre combarel
ce qui compte présentement c'est que
monsieur de choiseul soit ici nos chers
si vous saviez comment j'ai quitté les
tuileries hier soir il y avait dans le
couloir de la chambre une horrible
sentiments et le croiriez-vous elle ne
voulait absolument pas tourner le dos il
m'a fallu attendre plus de dix minutes
enfin finalement l'homme s'est détournée
et j'ai grandi dans le couloir le bon
dieu sur le monde et notamment s'ils
n'avaient pas été là ça avec moi les
pandores il figurez-vous qu'en voulant
rejoindre la voiture qui attendait place
du petit carrousel
je me suis perdu lundi dans les rues
pour les tuileries et le loup je me suis
retrouvé au bord de la rivière
monsieur chazal tirs vous avez bien une
centaine d'hommes sous vos ordres n'est
ce pas ah non c'est non une quarantaine
seulement mais il ya là une soixantaine
de hussards commandé par un lieutenant
allemand n'y avait malheureusement
monsieur drevet dia commis l'imprudence
de laisser boire saison occupe deux
raisons faut dire à son excuse qu'il
ignorait qu'il aurait jamais en escorté
votre majesté
ils attendaient le passage d'un convoi
d'argent non plus bref ces hommes
joliment qu'elle peut encore de caissons
ivre mort ce qui commence à ouvrir une
bouche pâteuse très vive la nation tu
sers de nine 115,04 le travail dame
aussi ai-je appelant à se mettre à votre
majesté je vous écoute on fait avec
j'ai ici 40 us à mes shows sont fourbus
mais je vais faire démonter cet homme
votre majesté montera les choses dans
mon seigneur de dauphins dans ses bras
tandis que la reine malade du diabète et
ces dames se partageront les eaux je
vous en taureaux et des 30 points qui
restent nouveaux font jour et on croit
que de ça surtout ceux qui opposeront
galoperont ainsi jusqu'à demain là nous
retrouverons certainement monsieur
douillet a mis à la rencontre votre
majesté louis cyr sitôt notre arrivée
ici j'ai envoyé un homme le maréchal des
logis aubriot informé le général
bouillie de l'arrivée à varennes de
l'arma geste je pense aussi enfin du
vrai jespere que le jeune chevalier
bouvier aura pas de son père dès qu'il
aura pays la cruelle position dans ce
registre
votre plan est logique monsieur de
choiseul logique mais le peuple me
semble bien excité j'ai entendu ses cris
jusqu'ici et ne pensez vous pas que
lorsque nous montrons à cheval entouré
par vous ils réagiront avec violence
répondez vous que dans cette bataille
inégale de 30 contre 7 à 800 hommes ou
qu'un coup de fusil le tueur à la reine
mon fils ou ma fille ma soeur si la
telma leur arrive à attirer pour avoir
vu mon conseil
le seul parti que l'usap en train de me
tuer sous les yeux le temps d'ajuster ne
servirait à rien à perdre 1 m sur wii en
voyant résonnant froidement la
municipalité je n'aurais plus pas de me
laisser partir
elle me demande simplement d'attendre
que le jour soit le pcr je supplie la
voix de me croire c'est immédiatement
qu'il faut l'essayer deux parties non je
ne peux pas faire courir un tel risque à
ma famille mais si votre majesté tarder
sa perte et certains certaines mais oui
sarre sont gagnés par le peuple comme le
sont les jeunes mathieu rodrigues le
pouvons france et nous sommes encore
maîtres de la rue ils n'oseront pas
qu'il veuille sur la famille royale
non je préfère de beaucoup la solution
proposée par la municipalité
et si au jeu à la municipalité poussé
par le peuple refusé de laisser partir
votre majesté mais telle catastrophe
pour le pays
il est de la plus grande importance que
votre majesté gagne au plus vite la
place corps de montmédy où se
cristallise autour d'elle les forces
vives du royaume et ben non majesté
votre voix toute sa force toute sa
puissance toute son autorité
certes aussi de choisir - d'autre
solution pour que la france sorte du
désert pour qu'on attendait des ibères
hors de la pression de la rue
quelle gifle heures mettant les gens
votre majesté gouverner au mieux les
intérêts de son peuple
je sais très bien où se trouve mon
intérêt du mon désir est de gagner
montmédy le plus rapidement possible
voyons en raisonnant le jeanne rouiller
a dû partir de varennes vers 11 heures
du soir pour aller prévenir son père
c'est la ji position si nous ne sommes
certes inclus départ du maréchal de
logis en voyez pas monsieur de gobelets
à une heure du matin
bon eh bien il devrait se trouver as tu
des vers 3h30 est ainsi pris et à stenay
le royal allemand devait être prêt à
monter en selle depuis huit heures du
soir c'est là en effet le plan monsieur
faire de fersen excellent plan excellent
pl donc si la jeune de bouyer a pu
prévenir son père le régiment sera là
vers 5 heures au plus tard vers 7 heures
si le général de bouyer a été prévenue
par votre émissaire ah oui c'est vrai et
si la municipalité ne changent pas
d'avis mais c'est donc bien entouré que
nous gagnerons mon mythe
si la municipalité changer d'avis ici
ils n'oseront j'ose vous assurez
monsieur que lorsqu'ils verront deux
mille cavaliers sur la route de stenay
ils n'oseront pas s'opposer à ma volonté
a comme toujours votre majesté voit très
bien la situation
espérons que le peuple reste ça mon cher
vivent depuis deux années le roi fait ce
que tout le monde vous ne pensez vous
pas qu'il serait temps que le peuple
fasse pas plus que le roi battant de la
rue polonceau j'espère non mais tu as vu
leur ligne de bataille
je suis allée cavaliers sur les hauteurs
de chypre et malte être l'avant garde le
bouillet non c'est plutôt les hussards
qui arrive de la prob une chars dans
toutes les rues et d'autres en vaches du
pineau maison maintiennent les
barricades le pont et bien barré de ma
chair et de meubles est toujours là je
ne sais quoi comme jeu meilleur jet mais
le principal c'est qu'ils parcourent en
bouillie highway mis sur le cul crafton
déménagement est à charette de meubles
qui a privé oui ce maudit bouyer batum
un sacré serait bien capable de brûler
la vie est belle mais nous serons nous
défendre nous tous les chemins tous les
accès bras pour habiliter air valid on
sait les militaires comme nous qui à
carillon puis la batterie quand vous
n'allez pas vous disputez un an
l'ennemi est dans la rue on peut aller
mieux désormais les hussards battu déjà
but mais bien gallardo comme ça qui le
domine du haut de leurs shows voilà nous
aussi à pac man o on a eu un détachement
d'aristocrates on l'a mis à la raison et
lui aurait plus forts à varennes
nous on les a gagnés noise tard on en
effet dès sa vie va garder sa vie du
peuple et ceux qui sont dans la rue on
le gagnera aussi et ceux qui arriveront
ils tous et ma femme est en train de
leur part les réponses sur ce lâchage
remplacer choisi leur donne l'ordre
la demande en tournant le plus frais et
viennent d'arriver hansson autant que
c'est bien tout le village
nikos d along du large capable en a
donné aux usa avec des brosses vallat et
même la mer fleurantins qui s'engagent
au jambon à la volée
c'est normal il avait inventé le foot à
y vivre ici et tous ces patriotes a
longuement comme ici à l'arrêter le roy
on peut dire maintenant mais peut-être -
pierre verdy le plus irritant majeur
on a tiré et roland hier l'as
l'annoncions laissez-passer à séoul à
vous tirer sur un objet français
maintenant je suis désolé et quoi il
fallait pas lui menacé tout faire ça va
ils saccagent et dépose la balle et
c'est pourquoi aussi diable avez vous
créiez comme ça
bon j'ai connu deux rondes par khartoum
a répondu en criant vive la nation créé
l'état nation n'est pas une injure eva
fallait faire comme des délires comprend
que nous avons raison mais moi monsieur
je crie vive le roi cela dit je suis
désolée nous avoir blessé j'étais blessé
de l'aude et tiré sur nos soldats
rentrent glas non mais ce n'est rien je
vous assure un bon de les excuser
oui vous partez avec la loi mais
certainement monsieur leroy vient me
dire que vous ne vous en privez pas à
son départ et leur donne en face à tes
sa berline le jour se lève le roi peut
poursuivre son voyage à parce que vous
vous imaginez que le roi va comme vous
dites poursuivre son voyage
et pourquoi ne fait-il pas si telle est
son désir parce que nous nous y opposons
de vous que doivent se poser aux
affaires du roi monsieur dans le cas
présent si elle quoi ça parce que le roi
en rompant le pacte qui le lie à la
nation a cessé d'être sont chers lorsque
le roi a trahi la nation
on l'associé levier qui n'est plus le
chef de la nation qu'on le laisse qui
pourrait agir non parce qu'on a besoin
de lui pour que l'essai que le roi du
monde
peut-être mais le roi qui est vraiment
le roi un roi qui reste à son poste -
monsieur groupe alors pas du tout ma
mort
là mon post à moi exige que je
transmette les ordres du capitaine venir
assemblée bezonnes fournir un poil
escorte jean féger le virois il ya une
chose que vous oubliez monsieur c'est
que maintenant les municipalités ont le
droit de requérir l'armée
le roi l'a d'abord avoir les
municipalités je connais les nouvelles
lois aux sigles des gens c'est alors
vous n'ignorez pas que les troupes prêté
serment à la nation au roi et à la loi
et que l'assemblée a décrété qu'elle ne
devront jamais être employée contre les
citoyens chignon et vos hommes
totalement qu'ils sont en train de
comprendre ils n'ont pas pu le roi
ordonné à ses troupes de pointe et se
servant mais il se remet on ne veut pas
dire que ces troubles doivent d'agir
contre le roi a semblé bonne qualité
j'attends les ordres de la municipalité
bon rugueux de toute façon le roi peut
très bien se passer je sais c'est scort
de boutiquier de 10 ans si vous le
permettez monsieur le dit les
boutiquiers les paysans vont se réunir
en conseil à l'hôtel de ville et c'est
là on décidera on ne laissera pas enlevé
par des gens comme vous enlevez tous ici
nous n'avons qu'un choeur avec une
pensée garder le roi en france ne
voulons pas laisser partir avec vous
pour l'étranger monsieur lorsque le roi
est présent à personne pas plus fou que
moi du quai faire nous pouvons dire nous
voulons vous vous trompez monsieur
depuis la prise de la bastille le peuple
et ses représentants de l'assemblée peut
se dire aussi nous voulons vous en prie
monsieur dû à mon colonel joue trop me
quesneau rémy dragons de monsieur
voulait fermer oui monsieur demain on va
vous dire que son détachement été gagnée
par les habitants des deux fours et mes
camarades à meetic vip d'horizon certain
nombre les habitants se sont doutés
quelque chose les dragons légende
clermont eu la même réaction des gens
crier vive la nation
une seule voie c'est unanimement planète
unanime
pc de parts et d'autres mon colonel
cette dame a lorsque je suis parti
n'avait que quatre ou cinq hommes avec
les et là-bas ce ne sont pas des
allemands messieurs mais des français
[Musique]
devant le roi puisque le roy avoue le
père et les petites quêtes ici
[Musique]
donc comme selon des tacles
on
[Musique]
c'est tocsin que l'on entend toujours on
entend aussi sonné ceux des villages
voisins mais tranquillisez vous madame
la puce
la municipalité ne refuse pas de nous
laisser partir au jour et le jour élevé
[Musique]
alors j'ai choisi 6800 sont passés au
peuple comme ceux de clermont
et comme seule crainte que nous mais les
vôtres vous les aviez bien en main n'est
ce pas oui c'est en fin du mois je
croyais vraiment refuser le virage 7
l'aube là maintenant ils ont pris un
officier de la garde nationale de
varennes pour les commandes et les
disciplines et partout a clairement la
surrection est encore plus significative
là-bas ce sont des français ayant refusé
de venir
monsieur de choiseul il faut sortir de
cette indécision ordonné cyr j'obéirai
ma vie et à votre majesté je n'en doute
pas ce noir devant le retard
inexplicable de monsieur de boulier et
pour faire quelque chose
monsieur destot est à l'entrée du pays
avec ça rend tout ça suffit seulement il
a banni ce prix n'est ce pas
certes madame et tous les goûts et à la
monarchie ils s'apprêtaient à charger et
de blues aurions fait jour avec monsieur
degaugue la région trois hommes restés
fidèles
non non non monsieur chose non oui je
connais le cadre de votre majesté aussi
conseillé à monsieur des stands attendre
monsieur douillet vous avez très bien
fait mon cher duc
il ya aussi parents la route une
barricade qui va semble infranchissable
il faudra mettre pied à terre à la
prendre d'assaut
décidément c'est cul terreux ils sont
adroits oui a droit
très adroit et bien attendons
[Musique]
attendons
monsieur de chazal asseyez vous je vous
en remercie
[Musique]
vous aussi monsieur dowd l'ajout prix
mais c'est certain mais on rapproche
mais vous avez vu seulement de la ville
louée 50 ans avec son fusil et 50
d'ailleurs y ait une charrette de vivre
c'est le montre qu'on viennent d'arriver
au 6 février d'avant cours sur l'appui
des gens qui la carte ici avec les
fameux le double remise pour tenter
chahut
elles ont apporté avec elle des
charrettes de vivre en rambo re silence
silence
la séance est ouverte d'abord pitié on
m'a dit que tu avais envoyé mangin à
paris avait créé un billet christ y
avait dans ce billet je vais venir le
brouillon messieurs là là on nous
trouvons nous autorisons ne se mange un
chirurgien à varennes à partir sur le
champ pour y venir l'assemblée nationale
que le roi est ici alors là le concept
ils se fichent la ville et trouver se
renier les outrages de la magistrature
payet en structures populaires l'apa
citant arthur quoi puis la belle
structure quelque chose oui tu es toi tu
n'es pas membres des conseils mais c'est
moi c'est nous tous qui vous et mobile
alors que même le droit de te parler noé
mais pas de parler à tort et à travers
il trouve la séance en mieux empêche de
délibéré ou ses pontes libéré mais si
dans cinq minutes vous n'avez pas pris
des mesures le peuple sera là tout sera
l'hôtel de ville vous allez chante ici
alors
autant dire alors laisse maintenant
gagner mais tout s'est bien passé pour
le oui bon c'est bon mais ce mille
briques de plus à l'est et il apporte
tout à fait tort les pêcheurs je termine
ma lecture vous prévenir l'assemblée
nationale que le roi est ici pour la
supplier de nous tracer la marche que
nous devons tenir
oui j'ai ma vie ni signé les officiers
municipaux de varennes bon mais nous
n'aurons pas leur réponse avant deux
jours au mieux un jour et demi ne
pouvons pas attendre jusque là avec tout
ce monde dans la rue mais on l'a promis
au roi qu'on laisserait partir au jour
même qui moi bréchet et les jours oui
mais le peuple ne laissera pas monter
dans sa berline
et puis avant nous le droit de laisser
partir est-ce qu'on commet pas là
comment disait-il
le suédois est un crime de lèse nations
amies les nations comme on disait
autrefois les majestés ah oui un
attentat contre tout le pays
oui c'est grave très grave la majorité
libéraux ne s'est pas encore pris de
décision se montre les français vous
êtes fous alors parce que vous êtes tous
furent graciés par le roi pour lille et
sept-îles et non non nous savons très
bien que ce qui était possible il ya
quatre heures ne l'est plus maintenant
que le peuple a parlé et fort bien
parler d'eux les mêmes les hussards de
choiseul pactisent avec nous oui ils
m'ont pris comme chef
j'ai quarante hommes depuis ses touts
chasse tous à cheval est bien l'armé oui
mais ils sont tellement je ne sais pas
ce qu plomb lorsque nous aurons devant
tous leurs camarades du royaune allemand
dire en tulle qu'entre lalonde ont écrit
des damnation tout leur coeur m et
n'ayant encore les gardes nationaux des
environs qui me demandent de les
commander un tuner village pensent comme
nous tous regardés a clairement oui à
sainte-menehould et puis tous ceux qui
sont ici mon bras ville aux preuves il
vienne le château montpon âprement
qu'est ce que vous en a près les rois un
grand monsieur ne voyait arriver ou
convaincra peut-être pour lui expliquer
que vous ne pouvez pas laisser partir le
roi en admettant bien sûr
c'est pas tout ce massacre auparavant
écouté le muret sont vos réflexions
moi je crois utile d'aller placer
mécanos du coach épices et par là
qu'arrivera bouyer en éclatante
car ils s'éclatent rond mais canon les
frères ont peut-être bon et ben nous on
avoue délibéré on va consolider les
barricades prévient roland ries a il est
vrai père chose que tu peux pas le
laisser dans sa chambre jusqu'à la
réponse l'assemblée avec les gosses dans
son lit et les autres qui mangent des
provisions écoutez on devrait geler
répartis un peu chacun vancouver moi moi
je veux bien la reine ça fait très mal
par les bêtises
pourquoi pourquoi je devrais faire les
foins à la haine bon maintenant il faut
savoir ce qu'on va faire
bath gagnons du temps voyez le wiimake
les jours et tu leur a promis qu'il
partirait vos jours oui oui c'est vrai
il fait jour après jour
baboo jours déjà depuis longtemps
monsieur le duc ne reconnaissez pas je
ne prévois avec les officiers la garde
nationale monsieur le duc ma vie
autrefois ce monsieur de puységur
j'étais censé péters dans le mille
pardons
pourriez-vous me présenter à sa majesté
pourquoi nous en sommes croyez vous que
ces formalités soient vraiment
nécessaire étant donné l'importance de
ce que j'ai à dire à sa majesté je tiens
monsieur vous présenter à sa majesté cir
est la bonté de le permettre
sir me permettez vous de vous présenter
monsieur sur rade et sur rade ait
appartenu à monsieur de puységur il
demeure représentants darrell et
semblait trop gros sujets du roi désir
sans trop tenir votre majesté votre
majesté ou à cette fenêtre
non que votre majesté ne s'avance
pourrez la voir cette fenêtre donne sur
une ruelle la ruelle de la barade qui
conduit au chant en effet six officiers
pour est enlevé le roi gagner les champs
et joindre ainsi le campement de
monsieur le bouille et moi seul ah je ne
crois pas qu'on pourrait faire passer
par là la reine princesse ces dames mais
sa majesté pour y revenir avec michel
bouyer et puis ici je vous demande
pardon madame mais seul compte le roi le
roi partie on inquiéterait pas sa
famille la bande à messi
ne laissez pas votre fils aux mains de
la populace tranquillisez vous madame
il me semble beaucoup plus sage
d'attendre ici monsieur de boulier il
est maintenant plus de quatre heures
je ne pense pas que le royal
on va tarder à arriver j'aurais pu
joindre la barricade et parler à
monsieur des longs qui attend toujours
des ordres non monsieur non votre projet
ne me semble pas réalisable je prie sa
majesté de bien vouloir m'excuser par
contre monsieur il me vient une idée
sans attendre davantage des
délibérations de la municipalité
si vous alliez données bien positivement
l'ordre de ferhat les ma voiture bien
positivement jeu c'est là une excellente
idée
à trop majesté veut dire avec l'autorité
que vous donne votre défense de la
commune oui je vais essayer allez
monsieur radès vous avez carte blanche
il nous appartient de tout tenter
monsieur de choiseul t1 quelle heure est
il
rappel 86
et la municipalité galibert toujours
enfin il nous reste une heure à attendre
je ne pense pas que monsieur douillet
soit là avant 5 heures je ne pense pas
non plus les ir
cyr
la municipalité varennes a décidé je
rentre en majesté ne pourrai point
partir décider monsieur vous n'avez
point de parole c'est le conseil qui a
décidé et bien j'attendrai ici qu'est ce
que votre majesté à temps mais sa
majesté attend l'arrivée de monsieur de
bouyer qui doivent y en a cherché et
l'escorté etc les honneurs qui lui sont
dus
dans ces conditions je crains que votre
majesté ne soit plus en sécurité ici
monsieur ni troupes ont pris l officier
de la garde nationale pour les commander
c'est donc à vous et veiller sur la vie
du roi
ils ont répondu sur votre tête est bien
entendu vis-à-vis de la nation
monsieur de bouyer d'une l'antenne par
les appareils apparaît ici ils ont
compris et dès la première heure
il faut qu'ils parlent pour paris il
faut prendre une décision une décision
va ici vous me donneriez à l'abri d'une
décision pu se laisser partir ses pages
oui mais vous lui mais c'est dans cette
épicerie là dans la mélasse et les
chandelles c'est presque aussi idiot que
de le laisser aller à l'étranger mais
montmédy parce que avant de passer à
l'étranger
il va essayer de rester à montmédy pour
quoi faire mais pour y organiser la
guerre civile à montmédy
il appellera lui tous ceux qui ont
quitté le royaume depuis la prise de la
bastille dès le lendemain du 14 juillet
ses frères les polignac et tous leurs
amis ont fichu le camp à l'étranger ils
rappliquent rochus à montmédy à 4h10 6
mai oui bien sûr ils seront peut-être à
tous à montmédy les émigrés oubliant
époque les ny à rejoindre le roi il y
aura tous ceux qui sont encore en france
tous les nobles qui depuis deux ans ont
perdu leurs privilèges
tout ce que la nation engraissait pour
ne rien faire comme le châtain d'ici
qu'est ce qu'ont lieu les chacals une
paille nous coûter cher aussi cher que
le pur lévesque et quand le roi aura mis
sur pied une armée mais il marchera sur
paris mais oui à paris pour rétablir son
autorité comme ils disent
pour que tout redevienne comme avant
avant la réunion des états avant la nuit
ils ont abandonné leurs privilèges la
nuit du 4 août avant tout les lois que
nos députés ont voté à paris alors à
leur sauce alors il attend l'arrivée du
général de bouyer qui doit l'accompagner
à montmédy
qu'est ce que je vous disais bon bain
puisque voulait pas prendre de décision
moi je vais leur parler vous allez voir
les amis les amis et au roi refuse de
partir ne veut pas quitter varennes on
ne croyait pas que c'est parce que le
pays lui plaît c'est pour attendre le
général de bouyer qui campe en ce moment
vers bahreïn avec un régiment tout un
régiment de hussards il vient enlever le
roi pour le conduire à montmédy
et au milieu de l'armée des aristocrates
qui va se former et ce sera la guerre
oui la guerre civile des gars comme vous
et moi qui devront se battre contre ceux
qui veulent que tout ce qu'on a fait
depuis deux ans soit supprimé oui ce
sera la guerre et il ne restera plus une
pierre de votre varennes de montfaucon
une bille ou de bombes la ville
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
monsieur choisel quelle heure est il un
quart avant 5 heures
alors monsieur et vous pu faire appeler
selon les désirs d'un geste et je
reviens des écuries les trois gardes du
corps sont razi prisonniers quant aux
postillons il refuse d'appuyer pourquoi
ils ont rien à voir dans tout cela ils
attendent les ordres de la municipalité
les ordres de +50 sommes bien armés
gardent la berline alors ils vont
expliquer que l'intérêt de bahreïn était
baissée dans quel rôle je leur ai
expliqué monsieur le maire mais ils
n'ont pas du tout muller ne me
comprendre je regrette
[Musique]
c'est la grand mère de mon mari est un
peu dur d'oreille
elle est venue à pied de boer oeil dès
qu'elle a su elle est née ya si
longtemps c'est même plus comme sûrement
sous louis xiv alors bien sûr votre
majesté comprendre pour à elle le roi
c'est comme dans l'ancien temps
doucement
avec madame
elle aimerait tant voir le dauphin vous
permettez je vous en prie
voulait parvenir l'ancien régime
alors vous n'avez qu'à laisser partir le
roi
et tout redeviendra comme avant
savez-vous ce qu'ils ont fait nos
députés depuis deux ans qui travaille
pour nous la déclaration des droits de
l'homme et je la connais par coeur la
déclaration l'homme possède des droits
naturels et imprescriptibles la liberté
la propriété la sûreté et la résistance
à l'oppression
tous les citoyens ont droit de concourir
à la formation de la loi elle doit être
la même pour tous
nul ne doit être inquiété pour ses
opinions
tout citoyen peut parler écrire imprimer
librement la noblesse est abolie plus de
jus rendent ni de corporation
[Applaudissements]
tout cela sera supprimé oui voilà ce
qu'ils ont voté nos députés le 26 août
89 et nos députés c'est vous c'est nous
citoyens de bahreïn
vous avez arrêté le roi c'est le pouvoir
exécutif
il doit exécuter les lois et les décrets
votés par l'assemblée
emma temps qu'il reprenne le chemin de
paris
monsieur et faut partir pour paris vous
et votre famille quel ton j'ai vous
employez enveloppe par l'endroit
mais de quel droit me donnez vous des
orgues du droit des nos touches du droit
de tout le peuple qui est là dans la rue
pour les près de 8000 maintenant il en
vient depuis clairement et se disent ils
est sont en août
si le roi reste ici pouilles et si
violents vont tous massacrés il ya des
femmes dans la rue et même des enfants
si le roi reprend la route de paris si
le roi rejoint l'assemblée tout se
passera bien fait donc appelé monsieur
oui mais bon mon béni non pour paris le
roi vient de paris qu'il y retourne en
somme messieurs vous voulez tous vous
débarrasser de moi mais qui est debout
le chantre de varennes mais j'ai
confiance dans la municipalité de barel
et dans sa garde nationale et elles
n'ont pas émis le voeu que je retourne à
paris
je reste je t'en vas mal se terminer
monsieur pardon aux envoyés de
l'assemblée
nous arrivons de paris enfin alors droit
est ici un oui c'est moi dans mon
épicerie depuis 11 heures une épicerie
comment vas tu dès la fin de la matinée
l'assemblée nationale et monsieur de
lafayette ont envoyé des courriers dans
toutes les directions pour empêcher le
droit de poursuivre son voyage c'est mon
camarade le lieutenant romeuf qui est
officier dans de lance du général
lafayette wilaya et moi même je suis le
commandant bâillon de la garde nationale
de paris
nous avons été assez heureux pour
prendre la bonne route et en chemin nous
avons rencontré votre envoyé à
l'assemblée on est diablement heureux de
vous voir arriver où j'aime et je
regretterai pas citoyenne varennes
chance très fier votre municipalité en
retenant le roi a sauvé la nation parce
que le roi a certainement été enlevée
mais la france entière va avoir les yeux
fixés sur vous vous avez évité une
guerre déjà vous avez sauvé paris était
alors présente à un feu et à sang
je suis parti de paris une heure après
vous commandant écoutait est un peu plus
calme j'ai vu de ma chambre de cerises
installé sur ledit de la reine et qui
criait alors là c'est bien tant mieux
aussi avec les doigts accroché à la
porte du château logis à louer je veux
dire que les parisiens n'ont pas pris au
tragique l'événement l'assemblée
nationale a vu plus clair heureusement
le pouvoir exécutif en fuite
c'est grave non à moins que cette fuite
ne vienne prouver justement que l'on
peut s'en passer
oui quoi se passer du roi comme dans en
attendant l'assemblée nationale désire
que le roi lui soit ramené le plus
rapidement possible mon camarade apporte
avec lui un décret de l'assemblée qui
vous est destinée de l'assemblée
nationale oui fois les députés ont voté
à la chambre et me retrouver là d'un
décret mais sami ne vous est pas destiné
c'est ton roi comme moi de remettre à
l'endroit où aller
c'est fini pour nous on va repartir pour
cinq mois nous on va les préparer une
entrée au 1
oui mais quelle nuit des artistes est-il
encore monsieur leur vote l'officiel
monsieur lafayette a cru apercevoir un
autre site mais garde nationale devienne
le téléport de l'assemblée a su
conserver sans doute pas que tout paris
sait gorge
nos femmes et nos enfants sont peut être
menacée vous n'avez pas plus loin sur
l'intérêt de l'état enfin le femmes nous
enfoncent suis-je pas merci
bayon commandant le 2ème bataillon la 7e
division et que voulez vous si rennes un
décret de l'assemblée donné c'est mon
camarade qui la porte vous je ne
l'aurais jamais cru
l'assemblée nationale décrète ordre
d'arrêter ou de faire arrêter toute
personne quelconque sortant du royaume
dans le cas où les courriers joindrait
quelques individus de la famille royale
les fonctionnaires publics garde
nationale ou troupes seront tenus de
prendre toutes mesures nécessaires pour
empêcher que la route soit continuer et
de rendre compte de tout à l'assemblée
nationale
[Musique]
il n'y a plus de roi en france
tu ne peux pas question oui mais enfin
bon
[Musique]
veuillez me laisser seul je vous prie
avec les deux envoyés de l'assemblée
thérèse aussi madame
monsieur phase
c'est monsieur de la fayette qui vous a
ordonné de me faire prisonnier voici qu
il a été établi au nom de la patrie en
danger
je prends sur moi toute la
responsabilité du présentant mesures
cet ordre s'étend à toute la famille
royale et c'est signé la faille est sûre
votre majesté connaît l'attachement de
monsieur lafayette pour elle mais il ne
lui a jamais laissé ignorer que si le
roi séparé se pose est celle du peuple
il resterait du côté du peuple c'est ce
qu'il m'a prié de dire votre majesté
c'est vrai je le reconnais
[Musique]
il a suivi ses principes mais mon
intention n'était nullement de sortir de
france
le choix de la place forte de montmédy
si près de la frontière ne manque pas de
surprendre
je veux pouvoir gouverner faire
appliquer les lois de mon royaume sans
voir le peuple me juger on va dire
chaque instant ma résidence menacé ma
femme et mes enfants m'a insulté pis ce
faire le juge de ma conscience
oui mais pour pouvoir gouverner comme
longtemps votre majesté sans que le
peuple puisse le juger et en se mettant
sous la protection des troupes du
général de bouyer elle provoqué
immédiatement la guerre civile vous
conviendrez monsieur qu'il m'est
impossible de faire le roi à paris comme
le voudraient l'assemblée et le roi de
france doit rester à paris à paris où
siège l'assemblée qui représente la
nation
je n'ai pas les prérogatives de
l'assemblée
mais l'assemblée ne peut gouverner sans
le roi il n'est pas du tout dans mon
intention de prendre congé de mon peuple
et d'abandonner la place où dieu m'a mis
la place où dieu a mis votre majesté est
à paris et en quittant paris votre
majesté a creusé entre elle et la nation
un fossé qui sera difficile à combler
bien difficile je pense monsieur bâillon
que vous êtes de ce parti qui ne veut
pas de roi la france censée roi ne sera
plus la france
c'est un monsieur voyons que j'ai posé
la question eh bien oui cyr je suis
comme monsieur pétillon suite ce qu'on
désigne sous le nom de républicains par
principe comme lui je préfère un
gouvernement républicain à tout autre
parce qu'un tel gouvernement ne peut
être composé que dans ma principe
donneurs d'ordres gouvernants pour le
peuple est responsable devant les
représentants élus de la nation
je pense que bien vite ses traits public
puisqu'il faut l'appeler par son nom
deviendrait du despotisme non sire ne
peut être de despotisme lorsque le
peuple souverain
mais je suis déjà votre prisonniers mais
non si l'assemblée supplie simplement le
roi de ne pas poursuivre son voyage
vous appelez ça supplier elle ordonne
oui elle ordonne d'arrêter tous les
individus de la famille royale elle
m'arrête
vous allez obéir à cet ordre
oui s'il a semblé a décrété l'ordre doit
être exécuté si vous étiez contraint de
ne point d'exécuter le décret de
l'assemblée oui
comment serait-ce possible je vous
demande simplement de m'aider à différer
mon départ a pour attendre l'arrivée de
monsieur brouillé ne va pas tarder
maintenant
ainsi vous serez dans l'obligation de ne
pas obéir aux décrets de l'assemblée par
la force un nom sur ce n'est pas
possible
le décret voté par les représentants du
peuple et fort m pendant deux heures
considérez moi encore comme le roi de
france
[Musique]
si je vais voir les membres du conseil
de varaignes mais allez monsieur
c'est
je paie votre majesté de croire que je
vis 8 août à qui on ayant crevé des
chevaux pour m'apporter le déclin de
l'assemblée ont pour attraper le
commandant bayonne partie honorable
alors monsieur était moi retardé mon
départ
je suis tous les goûts et votre majesté
je suis prêt à donner ma vie pour elle
je supplie votre majesté toute forme de
blessure je pense que monsieur de
lafayette
si le roi c'est par sa cause de celle du
peuple
il est de mon devoir de rester du côté
du peuple le roi m'a demandé de l'aider
à différer son départ de deux heures ils
ont contraint par la force à ne pas
exécuter la décision prise par les élus
du peuple
l'at-on l'arrivée du général de juillet
veut se mettre sous sa protection se
séparer définitivement ma nation pour
qu'il parte s'il veut employer la force
sedouki encore on l'avait bien sûr la
peuplade qu'il partait nous sommes
maîtres
l'assemblée a décrété une agadez il faut
le remettre en voiture et pour paris cet
appareil matin vers 10h sur n'ouvre
lettre aux fidèles pour avoir un roi
plus longtemps qu un wiki retourne
louisiens jetées chaque jour on en veut
plus love et vous monsieur de vue ne me
dit rien ils ont raison il faut qu'il
reparte à paris vous si monsieur vu
wayne et young boys ou la violence
vous le savez répugne à montataire
angers s'est achevée flétri la violence
ma femme et la fille d'un officier de la
reine j'ai moi-même fait souvent mapouro
roi celui dire que je serais plutôt
tentées à me servir surtout puisqu'il
est dans le malheur mais un roi qui
déserte
non ce n'est pas possible n'est ce pas
rater mais tous par les lieutenants de
la maréchaussée des clermontois parlez
pas de mes poules rit bien vous l'avouer
maintenant il y en a une qui est en bois
peint et l'autre dans le canon est
bouché par un boulet avisé de la
maréchaussée du clermontois vont
représenter ainsi une partie du pouvoir
royal vous avez votre mot à dire puisque
c'est maintenant que martyr il ne peut
rien contre les troupes monsieur de
bouyer sous vous tirez au simple citoyen
que plus vite le roi aura quitté bar n 8
bat rennes sera sauvée mais bon partira
partira pour paris allez dire d'athlé ce
sera vite fait la compagne moi je vais
20 mois
[Musique]
merci il est bon votre jambon que vous
savez ils poussent au vin
non
vraiment merdique
on a aussi vraiment je lis parfois je
fais partie de ces gens qui mangent deux
fois plus lorsqu'ils ont des ennuis
ainsi deux sites octobre 89 j'ai dévoré
si bien vous rendre compte des décisions
du conseil municipal
vous devez rentrer à paris l'assemblée a
jugé le retour de votre majesté
indispensable à la sûreté des citoyens
vous supplions partir quels sont les
ordres
monsieur de choiseul vous voyez je suis
prisonnier et je ne puis vous donner
d'or
monsieur source
il est maintenant sept heures
accepteriez-vous de m'aider à retarder
un peu mon départ attendre les 11 heures
oui oui
voulez-vous un million de livres
ne me demandez pas ça c'est un mettez
vous à ma place
enfin je veux dire c'est plus que je dis
votre place est meilleure que la mienne
monsieur sources les responsables
cherchent où il ya peu ton père alliés
verts attendus dans les vergers des
pistes bleu clair bordé de blanc c'est
le royal allemand fâché l'avant-garde de
bouyer rama yade et jean-louis un geste
arrivant c'est une ruse pour gagner du
temps au pays pour qui paraissait plus
possible d'attendre entre amis dans sa
voiture par les pieds germain d'en
donner aux hommes on va voir bouger sur
le dos et pendant ce temps là là où ils
mangent pas été tout autrement de points
d'accès on voit bien les retenir pendant
une demi-heure au bataclan berline et
qu'ils ont mangé
on les jette dans la voiture les vergers
ainsi de cabriolets n'oublie pas les
gardes du corps mais qu'est-ce que j'en
fasse remplacer leur siège aussi la
geste est en train de se restaurer et
messieurs la période appelée en tournage
et ne peut plus différent
il tombait des nues je ressens 3008 est
ce que vous êtes en train de donner des
ordres au roi oui on m'en plains mentir
mais vous pourriez emporter votre pas
évolué rebond dans la voiture
mes enfants dorment encore je vous
demande je vous prie d'attendre encore
un peu
ils n'ont pas dormi de toute la nuit
dernière et et votre majesté ne seront
sans doute pas compte de situation dans
laquelle elle se trouve peut-être votre
majesté at elle eu tort d'écouter
certains conseillers indigne de son
estime et que le coeur du roi ce coeur
que je connais la pub condamné c'est
pour moi vous dit stop
si vous êtes reconnu tant mieux je suis
assez grand pour prendre mes décisions
tout seul on se tombe d'ailleurs forces
armées
je n'ai toujours eu en vue et je n'ai
encore en vue que le bonheur du peuple
alors pour faire son bonheur s'ils
repartent et je vais leur parler
les amis varennes en argonne
[Applaudissements]
ah ah
cet intrus et que le respect au dessus
de riz
je croyais être dans un tourbillon de
gens ailleurs l'esprit du monsieur de
lafayette
[Musique]
je suis bien obligé de reconnaître que
je me suis trompé
cette nuit à varennes me le prouve
et c'est là l'opinion générale de la
france fédérale
madame de tourvel
ok je vous prie faire lever monsieur le
dauphin est malade
seillier votre moitié suis pas l'idée de
barrett prendra soin de madame ben voilà
c'est comme quand j'appelais pour m
habituellement mccaw qui a surviré si
dans ce cas un second mais elle vous
prend les yeux genre comment allez-vous
dans les world as we et via tiendra
mieux la berline de sa majesté et devant
les fils et sort de la france est entre
vos mains cyr si le roi demeure ici ne
serait-ce encore que quelques instants
séjour comme d'ailleurs ceux de tous les
citoyens qui sont ici se trouveront dans
le plus grand danger
messieurs c'est toujours ordonner dans
ma vie et pour la première fois je
n'ordonne points je vous demande
la nation faillie bien votre place on
vous donne 24 millions par an je trouve
singulier l'équipe
[Musique]
c'est en
je suis citoyen avant d'être sujet
verdict monsieur de choiseul demeurer de
la disposition de la municipalité vous
aussi monsieur un commandant de la garde
nationale parisienne un boutiquier
déguisés en militaires de les arrêter un
colonel du cac perd 7 quel droit à
rennes vous adresser la parole du droit
des boutiquiers et des paysans déguisés
en militaires
vous allez certainement quitter le
royaume le décret de l'assemblée a prévu
votre cas vous l'avez entendu tout à
l'heure vous me laisserez au moins
exercé mes prérogatives je vous en prie
là
oh
[Musique]
à
voir le n'oubliez pas votre habitat
mais c'est passé le roi non postillons à
paris conduisez ces messieurs l'hôtel de
ville comment moi aussi je vais
l'envoyer d'assemblée vous pouvez partir
tout à l'heure mais après avoir été
interrogés
vous avez entendu grand mail il avoir
dit au postillons route de montmédy
route de montmédy
et maintenant il va peut-être avoir la
guerre la guerre à me dire
rien
d'oublier son chapeau
[Musique]
on